Hey there, fellas.
Put the kids to bed, cause today, we’re
gonna tell you about the opportunity of a
lifetime.
We know you’re used to getting spoon-fed
some lame anomaly by the squares at SCP Explained,
but don’t worry, we gave them the night
off.
It’s just you and me.
Allow me to introduce myself: I’m the proprietor
of a certain specialty gentleman’s club
that caters to a...Well, let’s say “discerning”
clientele.
You wanna know my name?
What are you, a cop?
Get outta my face.
Anyway, believe me when I say, the operations
of my totally legitimate business are deeply
tied to the activities of those narcs at the
SCP Foundation.
There are plenty of so-called x“scary”
SCPs, or “awesome” SCPs, or god forbid
“wholesome” SCPs.
But I don’t care about any of that.
The real question is: What SCPs are the hottest?
And I don’t mean hot as in literally, physically
hot, ya dingus, like SCP-001, the Gate Guardian,
and his crazy solar sword.
Though I wish my bouncer had one of those,
it’d be nice to chop the freeloaders in
half at the..whatayacallit?..the “atomic
level” or what have you.
I’m talking about SCPs that are total smokeshows
- And no, I’m not talking about SCP-3792,
an aerosol can full of black smoke that forms
humanoid figures.
But hey, if you’re into that, I can see
what I can do!
I’m talking about the kinds of SCPs that
they put an “Adult Content” warning in
front of.
Like SCP-4960, a literal sex and fertility
goddess - Lovely woman, by the way, we worked
together briefly in the 60s, but that’s
a story for another day.
Maybe you’re more on the furry side of the
equation with SCP-1471 and you download MalO
ver1.0.0 like it’s Tinder cause you Want
an appearance from SCP-1471-A.
If you have a thing for silver foxes, maybe
SCP-106 telling you a few of his “war stories”
might be a good way to pass the time.
And if you have a thing for literal foxes,
SCP-953, the Polymorphic Humanoid, might be
up your alley.
Sure, she might trick you into killing your
friends and eating your own organs, but ain’t
she just gorgeous?
And maybe even thinking about the Scarlet
King and his big, hunky suit armor makes you
blush as red as the blood he loves spilling.
I ain’t here to judge, we all like a bad
boy, and it doesn’t get much badder than
an interdimensional tyrant who wants to destroy
the whole multiverse.
If any of this got you feeling a little hot
under the collar - and you’ve confirmed
already that you’re not just experiencing
a fever from a rapidly-progressing SCP-008
infection - then my classy little joint might
be the perfect recreational establishment
for you.
Of course, we work on kind of an honor system
here, so I’ll tell you all about this on
the down-low as long as you promise to keep
it to yourself, capisce?
Cause if you double-cross me on this one,
some broken thumbs and pried-off kneecaps
will feel like a free vacation from what I’ll
do to you.
If you wanna find us, head down to East St.
Louis, corner of
street and avenue.
We’re pretty easy to recognize.
From the outside, we look like a single-story
brick building with real pretty colors.
Come over to the West side of the building
on Saturday at 2:00 AM, and buddy boy, we
will give you the time of your life.
You’ll know it’s time for the fun to begin
when my boy Big Mike exits the building and
starts setting up the signs.
One will be a sandwich board with a schedule
of the night’s entertainment, the other
is my pride and joy: The big, neon beauty
on the side of the building, reading “EXOTIC
GIRLS”
“or equivalent.”
Welcome to the Multi-Verse Strip Club.
You make your way in with a few hundred bucks,
and trust me, you’re never gonna wanna leave
- Though, full disclosure, we will boot you
out on your ass if you decide to linger after
3:30 when the show ends, if you’re still
alive at that point.
Did I just say alive?
No, I didn’t, you’re just hearing things.
You should really speak to a professional
about that.
Look, I’m not gonna treat you like a schmuck.
I could talk about how great the experience
at my club is until the cows come home, but
what reason do you have to trust me?
How about, instead, I tell you about the special
night a bunch of SCP Foundation D-Classes
spent in my club on their boss’ dime.
I don’t know how much you know about the
barbaric practices of those squares at the
SCP Foundation, but they ain’t big on human
rights.
They farm out prison inmates to be their personal
guinea pigs, and they have the gall to call
us unethical!
Being a D-Class is a thankless job.
They get sacrificed to monsters on the reg
and put in needlessly dangerous situations.
Hell, if 106 escapes, one of them gets put
in a femur-breaking machine, so their screams
of pain lure him back.
If anyone deserves a night of sexy fun in
my club, it was these three guys.
Here, even a Class D becomes a VIP.
And believe me, we hire our fair share of
Double-D-Class personnel here, too, and we
treat them right.
The D-Classes waited outside the club for
Big Mike to come let them in, then paid the
door charge with their Foundation moola.
Those jerks at the SCP Foundation made them
all bring in notebooks and pens to document
everything they saw.
Talk about adding insult to injury: You can’t
enjoy a night out if your head is stuck in
a stupid notebook the whole time.
You want your head stuck between a pair of
Wait, this is a family show?
Oh, uh, ask your mom about that.
Stay in school, kids.
Needless to say, when those D-Classes got
inside, they were real impressed with what
they saw.
Our establishment may not look like much on
the outside, but on the inside, baby, we got
it all.
Fine shag carpeting, mirrored walls, a disco
ball, luxurious and comfortable seating, and
a thick fabric curtain around the stage, where
the brass pole waits.
The guys were excited to get some more action,
and we were more than happy to oblige.
We started ‘em off nice and easy with the
Khünbish Sisters, the hottest pair of babes
the Tuvan Republic has to offer.
They have this incredible routine where the
pair of them sit naked on a log, and begin
an incredible round of Tuvan Throat Singing
- the exact same routine they did in Eurovision
1999 - while giving each other a tasteful
shiatsu massage.
Clearly, the D-Class fellas were enjoying
themselves, cause they made it rain on that
stage, and the Khünbish Sisters repaid their
kindness by singing a faster throat-singing
ditty - Which they performed in Eurovision
2003.
Next came one of my favorites.
Helen Keller took to the stage, a woman as
inspirational as she was hot, dressed in a
Vegas showgirl outfit.
Awooga!
Am I right, fellas?
She did a very classy strip show for the D-Boys
while performing a choreographed dance routine
to the song from Flashdance.
When the guys made it rain, she put a pause
on the dance routine and decided to recite
some poetry, which moved the boy to tears
and also led to them making it rain a little
more on ol’ Helen.
We figured, by this point, the boys were a
little more acclimated to our special brand
of sensual entertainment.
That’s why we decided they were ready for
the entertainment stylings of The Fantastic
Zippy...And Trainer.
If you thought the Khünbish Sisters were
a dynamic duo, then buddy, you ain’t seen
nothing yet.
It’s a lady and a live orangutan.
Oh, and the lady has no head, and also advanced
necrotizing fasciitis.
Fun fact: That’s the flesh-eating disease!
But don’t let that put you off, they don’t
call her The Fantastic Zippy for nothin!
Trainer, the Orangutan, gives The Fantastic
Zippy verbal commands to hit the pole and
do her routine.
Sure, some parts of her might fall off in
the process, but that’s only because she
puts so much energy into it!
When one of the D-Classes threw her a five-dollar
bill, she slipped it into her exposed trachea,
and Trainer ordered her backstage - Finishing
a routine that the surviving D-Classes would
never forget.
Did I just say surviving?
No, I didn’t.
You’re just imagining things.
Let’s move on.
We decided, after giving them a performer
with no head, to make sure the next performance
had a little more bite.
We released the girls, which is to say, four
velociraptors in perfectly-tailored Japanese
maid outfits.
They took to the stage with plenty of growling
and snarling.
The D-Classes, admittedly, started to look
a little fearful, but I’ve always thought
of fear as the greatest aphrodisiac.
I can only imagine that’s why two of the
three D-Classes decided to throw literally
all of their money at the stage for these
four very special gals.
The other D-Class split the rest of his money
between the trio as the raptors left, bringing
their spicy performance to an end.
Still, I think maybe these raptor gals have
a future in more mainstream entertainment,
especially if they crossover with the SCP
Foundation.
Maybe we’ll call it “Dr. Kondraki’s
Raptor Maids.”
I dunno, we’ll workshop the title.
Give suggestions in the comments.
Next, we proved to these D-Classes that we
can also stay up with the times, and provide
the cutting edge in sleek, modern, erogenous
technology.
We did this with erotic_performance.exe, a
program that runs on the incredibly advanced
Gateway 2000 computer and monitor running
a Fenestra 98 operating system.
It hit those boys with a series of equations
and 3D graphical representations that would
surely drive any hot-blooded fellas totally
wild.
In the end, they inserted a five-dollar bill
into the computer’s floppy disc drive, and
we moved them onto the next performance.
The Council of Libidinous Elders were brought
in next, to switch things up.
What, you’ve never heard of the Council
of Libidinous Elders?
Then you haven’t lived, my friend!
Each one is a levitating, gelatinous mass
filled with membranous fibers with powerful
telepathic erotic abilities.
They sent mental transmissions directly into
the brains of those lucky D-Classes, leading
to feelings of brain pain, mild acute tinnitus,
and most importantly of all, overwhelming
physical stimulation, baby!
We only had two performances left for them
at this point.
The first was a little number we like to call:
Serial No. 223244-09-P. Okay, we lied, the
number wasn’t that little.
This babe was all legs.
Literally, she was just a pair of mechanical
legs attached to an engine powered by pure
ambergris.
When the ambergris is poured in, she starts
the most elegant Riverdance you ever did see!
And for you crush fans out there, we even
put plates full of beetles underneath the
legs so she can smash them all up.
The D-Classes loved it - Until the pungent
musk of the crushed beetles made them feel
a little nauseous.
That’s what love smells like!
And for our most awaited performance of the
night, we brought in a special performer:
The Foundation dweebs call him SCP-1093, but
I call him something else that I’m not allowed
to tell you.
He’s a handsome dude wearing a sumo-style
mawashi, with a head so bright you literally
cannot see it, it’s a highly radioactive
ball of pure light.
And the version of him in my club also came
with a big, sexy, ornate stone ceremonial
knife.
He leaped into the crowd and wrestled one
of D-Classes, before using the knife to remove
their organs in a horrifying ritual sacrifice.
Did I say that?
No, no, no.
You’re just imagining things!
Don’t just hear about it happening to other
people.
Come on down to the Multi-Verse Strip Club!
We’ll give you a night not even amnestics
will make you forget!
Now go check out “Trapped in a Game - SCP-1733
- Season Opener” and “SCP-1861 - The Crew
of the HMS Wintersheimer” for more anomalous
spaces you certainly wouldn’t want to be
trapped in!